that I find that modern guys do
which
no what modern guys don't do which my
man does regular is telling me the truth
whether I like it or not thank you you
can't do that in this game no no you
can't no no you can tell me whether I
like it or not 100 I agree and I think
that you need to and sometimes I this is
right
I can't say that you don't care about my
feelings but he will my man will tell me
the truth whether and it's not like I
know how we fit what kind of truths
everything anything bro everything
listen right you know a fact you look
fat look at your face you look like
you've got two bits that'll never
hanging down if you did that now he'll
be he'll be in jail for emotional abuse
he'll be on some blog so so auntie I I
agree with you like I I think a lot of
men are afraid to tell women the truth
and I think more women would respect it
if they did but at the same but at the
same time
um modern women I think on some level
like to be lied to and don't want the
truth and they want to be sold to fairy
tale because we've been told our whole
lives were Queens princesses and tans I
realized that because I heard everybody
talking about this lizzo
and I saw lizzo for the first time last
this week
uh big
and I just thought to myself when I had
always talk about lizzo and I just
thought wow is that is that is that her
and I was just surprised that all the
yeah but there are no but there are no
standards for women right so lizzo can
can kind of have a physique that is not
as in line with what we generally
consider fit healthy attractive and
flaunt it in this like you know over
over kind of zealous way but men will be
scrutinized for like Leonardo DiCaprio
will be scrutinized for dating like a 25
year old even though he's a grown man
that's a grown woman yeah so I had no
problem with
a size
which wants to be fat that's her
business I hope she stays healthy I but
me personally I'm skinny and I wouldn't
wear what she's wearing but what but
what I found out that totally shocked me
is that
she can play
the flute she's telling to do it and she
is extremely talented but when I looked
at this woman on there shaking her stuff
and doing her thing
yeah I didn't put the two together and I
thought to myself why didn't you lead
with the fact that
you can really play the flute really
good rather than
at the shaking your stuff and
everybody's following her shaking and
she's leading with that and she's
leading the people away rather than how
did she get
to play the flute so good she must have
studied it or whatever but she's not out
there promoting that for the young
people for the modern people to say do
you know what I studied this I studied
music this is what I'm doing she's
promoting all the things what I would
say as negative when she's got so much
positive to give and that's I think I
can understand that why people are
following her that way I would respect
her more as she went out there and she
like dressed professional as a proper
it's not that's not that's not what the
model is it's not even programmed to do
that no forget the program it's just not
cool
like trying to like even
sorry so I'm gonna make this point she's
I've heard stories that like she will
sleep with guys and then throw them out
of a room as a power play like I've
heard she's deeply insecure in the way
she she handles herself out to me that
sounds like you're trying to be a man in
that you're trying to be like this alpha
male who has his way but you're not a
man you're you're female that's the only
time I saw her was playing the flu I've
never seen anything from her before
except her playing the flute and I was
impressive of her playing the loop I
thought why are you playing the flute
with a swing costume one
[Music]
oh did you
say like I think that people like Lisa
will do things like this because beauty
standards especially for the woman
reality yeah but no beauty standards
like for or like what a woman wants to
Aspire to look like he's actually based
on the standards that men also you know
set because men like [ __ ] they've
been liking [ __ ] since like maybe
like 80s
publicly publicly like through music
through like even culture through some
some of the things that are being
showing to us right which means that now
we got to a stage even like my friends
whenever they meet a guy first thing
they do is check who they're following
because that shows you like really most
a lot of men promote the [ __ ] culture
so I know that obviously modern women
have to take accountability but I think
it goes both ways and women like Lisa
are literally showing okay well I'm fat
and I'm all of this but if this is the
beauty standards out there I'm not gonna
let my body stop me I'm gonna be wearing
this the same thing that every guy
thinks this song
why is it the men promoting it no man's
making her go there she's trying to set
those standards and stupid people are
following her and then they're going to
turn around and say oh it's self-loved
obesity yourself love all of a sudden
and that's what she's promoting but it's
a man's not a man I don't think she's
abused I think she's generally like just
like a wider friend no she's not quite a
famous she's a blood she's got one
dinosaur I feel like she looks like
someone like she can't no matter what
she does she'll still have like a very
wise no she should tone uh
she's potentially
um she's potentially clinically obese
but she you can be obese and healthy yes
yeah you can be a fit her bees and you
can also be a very unhealthy
um skinny skinny person so she's
probably she's probably metabolically
She's metabolically Fit because for her
to play the flip like that with those
long dance jump up and down despite
despite the size but then if you take
height and weight and do the calculation
I just genuinely don't believe you can
be big for that long I'm not gonna
pretend I'm a science through a
nutrition like nothing but like I I
genuinely don't believe you can be big
for that long and not have health issues
must be putting a lot of strain on her
heart eventually potentially yeah but
she's better off than someone who's
completely sedentary she's mobile she's
mobile does that make sense but then now
it's yeah but anyways also sorry I
remember what I wanted to say Alex sorry
the only thing I wanted to say is that
why Lisa did not lead with them
um flute and everything because
education is not valid these days as
well guys just so you people know it's
not cool to go to UNI I am Juicy J I am
a host and presenter for Anna cover
aphrobeats events but nobody knows I did
my masters nobody knows I do undergrad
nobody knows I'm a stem student and I'm
a BSC and I'm Australia geek no one
knows that no one cares for that no one
asks that was a fun fact why didn't you
say it
because it's boring because it's boring
who is it boring for yeah
maybe that's the same thing Lisa was
saying exactly modern people think it's
boring I find that I find it really
fascinating and that for me that's
something you should lead with that's
true guys they're special more special
that is something that be careful makes
you in the truck everybody that is
something I don't know everybody
exactly but at the same time as a black
woman and you're now what you're
educated double educated you're you know
this is that you want to be a more you
just get away guys I want to get married
no no but that's what Society no that's
what society makes
scared by that unless you act like
you're better than them because of it no
but thank you no man no an average guy
can beat you up no man is intimidated by
you no no physically not physically but
I have had people no people come as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible